one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till too
[Music]
oh folks here we are we are here we're
drinking
it's sunday and uh we're podding
what's shaking fatty it's a day drink
yes and uh so i'm drinking a day drink
man this is
you know i'm doing a little americano
action
little campari vermouth vermouth
vermouth
i put a little over moose in my hair uh
a little vermouth
and uh some soda i i go lemon spin drift
it's kind of nice
oh a little day pick-me-up i like it boy
nobody consumed i think sam morill is
keeping the vermouth
companies in business you are the only
guy under 40
using three bottles of vermouth a week
i've been drinking dude i i've been i've
been i was at the cellar
the last two nights so oh nice it's hard
to just
see all these people you haven't seen
for a while and not get excited like
it's funny you're drinking throughout
the pandemic because you're like i'm
[ __ ] losing my mind but then you
start drinking
when you're seeing people because you're
like it's a celebration right right it's
so true and plus
just something in your biology and your
jeans you sit at that table you're in
that room
you're with your friends you're like
give me a cocktail you come guzzling
nazi you just it is needed it goes right
back to you
it's so nice man yeah it was great it's
great to see some of those
people again and uh the crowd was you
know it was like a small little open my
key setup but
they were good man is it still the
plexiglas
it's still the plexiglass but i think
we're we're moving away
hopefully yeah we're getting away from
that but i always say for the people who
don't know what the comedy seller just
to play it's
safe you're literally in a plexiglas
phone booth
delivering your jokes and it feels like
you're on an exhibit
of stand-up comedy in the future at the
smithsonian like this is what it used to
be like and you feel like the guy in
there
like wow this was an old art form that
got uh cancelled in uh 2024.
you feel like you're in there you feel
like they should take your spot pay and
just shoot money all around you have to
just grab it behind the thing
yes yes i got in trouble for saying it
was the louis ck
cage because you can't get hit
that's doing folks what uh
where were you this weekend oh man one
of the great clubs one of the great
weekends
uh columbus ohio funny bone best funny
bone in the nation
sold it out just killer not a bad show
in the bunch
three on saturday great time
that's wild man yeah we uh i i've been
there once i've never done the club i
did it i opened for a z's in a theater
in columbus and it was it was a
beautiful theater
it's a great it's a great city i would
i'm just gonna get me some uh some
twitter hate but i think best city in
ohio
i'm sorry cleveland i'm sorry cincinnati
over the rhine
i'm over it cincinnati's basically
kentucky
that's true that's a good point you take
a hop skip and a jump and you're in
kentucky
yeah it's just kentucky with skyline
chili that's that's cincinnati
and then cleveland cleveland's pretty
low-key cool though
i like cleveland i like cleveland but it
took a second they had a big chip on
their [ __ ] with the we're a factory
town and we got lebron
and the indians and all this but uh once
they got over that and
you know bought a bought a cocktail bar
and a vegan place
they they kind of turned it around when
when lebron left the first time they
didn't have that like i just got dumped
energy
and it was kind of like all right dude
calm down don't hit me
right on edge but they yeah but
cleveland they've kind of bounced back
they got the win they're kind of like
we're good now they had the biggest i
think sports drought of any city it was
like for 54 years
any sport totally and then boy they came
back hard with the with the baseball and
everything but
cleveland was such a big booming thing
in the 50s it almost feels like the guy
in high school who was
peaked and then now he's in college or
now he he's hanging out at the
at the high school parties and he's in
college and he's got the letterman
jacket on he's like yeah you know i
scored that touchdown against
mcgee in 88 and you're like all right
it's over move on
and i feel like they finally moved on
it's a real al bundy city yeah for sure
yes but they have the uh rock and roll
hall of fame is epic and they have i
mean cleveland i'm going to be there
next month i'm [ __ ] excited man i
can't wait hilarities
so oh that's a great club one of the
best clubs in the biz
uh sam and nick two of the best
well let's let's we you guys have been
sending us emails so we want to give you
some shine here because you've been
sending so many good emails should we
read
peeves rex jokes mark what do you what
should we start
by the way it's we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com if you want to
send them in we usually just do it on
the patreon which you should all sign up
for
but uh but if not you know give this
give us an email we might
we'll throw some of these out here and
there why not yeah yeah i met some uh
some fans after the show and they're
like we love we might be drunk
we love one more drink we love uh they
had every name
you know they're they're half in the bag
they're getting all the names wrong like
we love tuesdays with drinks and uh one
more stories they're like mixing
everything up god don't drink
you know they got me in a headlock you
know breathing on me but
uh it was fun it was it was great so
yeah that's the email that's the patreon
get on it
and this is a little taste for you to
wet the beak i got a raul
tele devara this is a pet peeve
calendar two of me baby oh yeah
it's called do what you want i hate it
when i ask someone for advice
on something important and they answer
back you should do what you want man
if i knew what to do i wouldn't ask you
for advice saying do what you want when
someone asks you for advice
contributes as much to the conversation
as dj khaled does
every one of his songs it's just one
line and then silence
that's a great great analogy dj khaled's
talentless
it's interesting uh it's a great point i
i hate when people do this
i i will ask doctors covet advice
sometimes i'm like well what should i do
about this or like
you should do what makes you feel safe
cool could have gotten that from a
cashier thanks for the thanks for the
assistance there
yes it's so empty and then the guy feels
cool he feels like mcconaughey with his
shirt off and a joint in the bongos like
do what you want man
it's all about spiritual and living life
it's like shut up get up get a job get a
haircut what are you
talking about it's it's the is it is
what it is of advice
exactly do you want it's like i wanted
to ask you
and i wanted some [ __ ] valuable
feedback thanks for nothing dick it
it's kind of like when someone's like
just be yourself and you're like hey
that's not i am myself this is me yeah
this is not helping me yeah me is the
one who needs help
i'm clueless myself i'm it sucks i'm
trying to be somebody better
that be yourself thing is a big uh big
ruse
yeah i remember i said it to someone
like years ago and i immediately was
like i'm sorry
that was awful right you know it was
himself
harvey cosby you know hitler
they were themselves jeffrey epstein
that guy did not need any help
being himself yeah yeah exactly be
someone else
totally i have a special call don't be
yourself it's too much
i i remember the whole thing started
cause there was a guy on the subway like
freaking out and rapping and yelling and
everything and somebody goes hey man can
you calm down can you chill out one guy
and he goes
i'm just being me i'm just being me
you're like yeah well don't
you suck we hate you be anybody else
you know when this all started with
reality tv
when people instead of being a [ __ ] they
were like i'm a personality
ah yes it became almost cool to be a
piece of [ __ ]
i'm being real cool be pleasant yes
exactly pleasant is better because no
one's ever phony
and mean no one's ever like you piece of
[ __ ] sorry i'm trying something new i'm
working on a new image
it's always mean it's always real
yeah that's true it's never it's not
mother teresa's never like i'm just
keeping it real
yes yes exactly yeah so
don't be yourself out there and do what
you want folks
but yeah yeah do what you want sucks
because what you want to do is nothing
so don't tell me to do what i want
because then i'll just go home and jerk
off and put pajamas on
what i want to do is punch you in the
throat forgive me that [ __ ] advice
there you go so great what i did tell
you to be yourself
sorry about that yeah i can't can't
press charges
all right thanks rahul that was good
stuff yeah that was i like that bro
i like a good peeve uh yes peeve gets us
going i kind of like it
oh yeah we're fired up let's see what we
got
um hmm i never told you what i was
drinking but i want to
i want to hear you what are you drinking
buddy holy [ __ ] no i gotta know oh all
right all right well it's midday
i'm going back to it feels like spring
is here
going oh [ __ ] full pickleback with the
pickle in it
and it's goddamn refreshing so you're
doing just
is that just pickle and whiskey pickle
whiskey
ice with a pickle spear in it damn
i've never seen someone i've seen people
do the shots i've never seen someone do
it as a cocktail
i feel like it's great it's all you
really need because the pickle juice
cuts it so much
it's perfect it's almost like a martini
with whiskey
you know you can do uh i almost did that
another episode but i didn't have the
vermouth i have the vermouth now
the driver moves i always have the sweet
but uh
you can do a martini just pickle juice
vodka a little dry vermouth and you got
a pickle martini
nice i might bring that i might bring
that to the uh show
in a week or two oh that sounds like a
great idea a little teaser
even get the little pickles instead of
olives yeah that's kind of nice
they used to do you know what they used
to do speaking of hilarities which is
one of my favorite clubs they used to do
a banana pepper martini and it was one
of the best things i've ever drank in my
life
because you get a little spicy but it
yeah it was it was pretty wild
that sounds great what a great idea you
feel like a real puss ordering it so you
got to drink that in the green room but
uh
yeah this is nice it's still savory
though that's that's what saves you
these guys i hate to say it i'm a [ __ ]
but i saw a couple guys this weekend
ordering a daiquiri with the [ __ ]
uh what do you call it the whipped cream
on top i completely lost respect for the
guy i
look i'm no tough guy i'm a twink and a
half but i see this guy
and i'm just like dude what are you
doing i would never hire you
yeah that would be great that would be
rough if you just hired someone for a
job and you saw him in a bar drinking a
daiquiri and you're like oh
i [ __ ] up daiquiri is
is for that's for the beach only i'm
sorry
yeah it really is it really is go to
hawaii or you're on the the beach in in
uh
puerto rico or something get a pina
colada get a daiquiri but i mean we're
at a comedy club for christ's sake
yeah it's it's too much like it it
doesn't tell me anything it just tells
me you're like you wish you were on
vacation that's all it takes
or that you can't handle alcohol at all
or that you have the palette of a
[ __ ]
nine-year-old boy what are you doing
that's what it is grow the [ __ ] up
get some hair on your chest grow a pear
and
i i'm somebody had a great joke who was
it about how
the people who drink the fruitiest
sweetest drinks are hot chicks and big
black dudes
and it's so true it's such a great
observation you know
i mean like blue lagoons with the
umbrella in it you're like what are you
doing man you're like
you're like this running back for the
the tampa bay buccaneers and you're
drinking a goddamn
you know slurpee it's so true i remember
mike yard wanted the seller
you know tough dude been [ __ ] shot
you know he's like you know much tougher
man than me
anyway uh he's drinking bailey's irish
cream and i was like ooh
i just started [ __ ] with him and he
goes i could still kick your ass i'm
like yeah
but yeah i still get to make fun of you
right i mean
if you're wearing a tutu you can still
kick my ass too but uh
i can still block you for it
you could you're gonna kick my ass but
afterwards you're gonna sit back down
and finish up bailey's irish cream
that's perfect that's so true yeah
who wins here i'm on the floor bleeding
and you're like oh
it's so sweet let me let me double fish
with a mango vape
[Laughter]
right right dimitri martin at this great
joke he's like i think we can get guys
to quit smoking we just put two
tiny balls on the cigarette so it's like
and i feel like i've never smoked it
again um that's [ __ ] good man
demetrius some good ones man
he had some great stuff i mean he's
still i think he's still writing so i
haven't seen him forever yeah no i just
said oh yeah well you write an hour like
that
it's one line at a time i don't know the
hell you like
yeah he's a dude that almost has to stay
off twitter because that might just be
the act
yes great point great point and i can't
tell you how many times i've had to
delete a tweet
because we were like dimitri did it and
i was like damn he's covered
everything yeah i mean if it's a
one-liner man
if it's a headliner i had a joke i was
so proud of on twitter
i don't know if i could put this in the
act but it was a it's
preposterous that food trucks don't
deliver
it's a [ __ ] truck and they're like
dimitri dimitri and i had to you know i
had to delete it
of course but yeah it's a great
observation when you do one that's
parallel thought with dimitri you're
like at least i'm
thinking the right way because that dude
he gets to it quickly
yeah that's true i mean he's got a great
mind check him out if you don't you
don't know him he's got a touchdown yeah
they've got to know him
yeah his comedy central half hour from
back in the day
uh i guess they're all in paramount plus
now i know if you got that email
but uh i did i did i love how they give
you no [ __ ] like the toolkit
the the promotional stuff like even
comedy central you know they send me
like a toolkit for that roast thing
we're doing
yeah and like and they're like here's
some stuff to promote it it's like
it's like a gif of me looking like this
i'm like why why would i post this i
look like
i look like i had a brain injury are you
guys like
trying to not get hits on your [ __ ] it's
so true i mean
all these netflix they all do it when
they show hey we got the new special
coming out for nate bargatsi
i shouldn't say him but like somebody
who's a comic and the the promo is like
i'll tell you what these kids today and
that's it
and you're like give me anything
punchline twist
nate's trailer was good and that
actually shocked me because most of them
are terrible
most of the trailer yes that's why i'm
like we
like we made our own trailers you know
what i mean so we get to kind of
when you sell produce it you can be like
well here's how i want it yep yep and
yours was
it was like what two minutes of just 19
jokes in a row and you're like you see
what we can do here but you queefs won't
do it you just put up a dumb setup and
then move on
you know what i like about you you use
queef as a positive and a negative you
use queef the way like jews use shabbat
and shalom like you know you're like
shalom
hello goodbye you use queef as a i love
you and go [ __ ] yourself
yes it's alone yeah and the way the
brits use kant you're kind of like this
[ __ ]
that's how you use queef you're taking
back queef i'm trying i'm trying well
and this sounds bad but i feel like
every negative term for like a wussy guy
is kind of homophobic
so i i want to keep insulting men
but i don't want to insult gays so i
made queef totally well that's good yeah
let's let's be progressive with it i
love it there you go
uh i got another one pepe from ryan
mandick
uh great last name mandic a great porn
star
[Laughter]
this guy's got a man dick that's [ __ ]
amazing
yeah maybe it's man ditch but i'm
pronouncing it mandic
either way either way he's [ __ ]
winning
either way man ditch she's still doing
the work in her head she's thinking a
dick if she's on a date with
that guy so right right sucks with a
daughter
vanessa mandic
[Laughter]
yeah what am i getting tonight i don't
know
here's a pet peeve for you when people
are telling you about a movie you really
want to see and they tell you there's a
huge plot twist
it kind of ruins a huge part of the
movie and when people
and when you call people after doing it
they always respond with but i didn't
tell you what it is
right right yeah yeah that is a little
much
i can live with that but i get it just
let me enjoy the movie because now
you're sitting there going when's the
twist
oh it's coming i'm okay if they keep it
really vague if they just go
incredible ending that's okay with me
that's fine
but uh man mackie uh our boy joe mackeys
have the best joke about plot twists
uh the crying game which if you haven't
seen it spoiler you should have seen it
it's a great movie but yeah the twist is
that she is a penis in the end
and uh and maggie goes if that's the
plot twist
you can just tell me
[Laughter]
you don't need i don't need to sit
through that whole movie
yeah i don't need to sit that whole date
either
[Laughter]
but yeah that's that's olympic god
mackie's so good that's so
funny i forgot about that movie yeah it
was a classic
it was it was like that was like that's
it's cool when there's i mean now you
can't make a movie like that anymore
because it would be all over message
boards but back in the day
i bet i bet it was a decently kept
secret
oh for sure yeah yeah also the big plot
twist
is tough because let's say you're
watching the sixth sense
which was like this huge big a blowout
movie
and i had no idea it was coming and it
made it that
much better for sure yeah i mean that's
kind of the good thing about watching an
old movie
that no one talks about that has a twist
like oh [ __ ] i had no
yeah i mean everyone knows usual
suspects everyone knows the big ones but
uh
right right that's why it pays to go
back and watch some of these because
nobody's talking about them so it's
super fresh
everybody wants new now new new what's
the new thing what's coming out what's
the hot songs like there's a ton
a ton of great art that people are just
especially younger people
they're missing out they're missing out
because you know
it's all about uh social media man
people it's hard like
i think people it's funny it used to be
hard to commit to a book now it's hard
to commit to a movie for young people
oh so true wow that's a great point yeah
i mean i got my gal here she's
she's 29 30 which is not that young but
i showed her good fellas and she i look
over and she's tweeting and tick-tocking
and i'm like
this is one of the greatest action-y
gangster like
funny it's got everything and just i
know it's long but you haven't gotten to
the first 20.
yeah it's amazing how many for some
reason goodfellas
as great a movie as it is is kind of a
man movie
i've showed it to women where they just
are kind of like yeah it's good
it's true yeah and i'm just responding
like that's it
i know but she can watch
90 day fiance and she's like this
character's full of [ __ ]
she's a liar he's cheating he's been in
jail like she knows
everything and i'm like this trash has
got you
stimulated but yeah it's not my gender
so you know i can't uh
they might see it differently much like
us with good fellas
yeah beyonce is [ __ ] weird yeah well
that's the show that we're on our phone
and they're like you're not paying
attention oh yeah i'm sorry i'm spacing
on this when you couldn't [ __ ]
give me 10 minutes in a row to score
stacey yeah
yeah women i mean i don't want to
generalize but women like reality
they like people they like relationships
they like interactions where i think men
like
creation almost scripted stuff
scripted i mean women like scripted
shows but reality i mean bravo is for
women
i mean bravo yeah bravo is for it's not
for men
yes yes and even women like lifetime
like all those rape movies and and home
intruder movies but like
that's because it's based on real [ __ ]
or could be real
or might happen to them or whatever it
is and it's just victimization
it's it's right uh it's like this is
like
you see us like a lot of movies are like
the women or the femme fatale
this is a woman who's actually being
victimized and they feel probably heard
i would think
yeah yeah maybe yeah that's probably
true and i think it's almost by a lot it
goes back to caveman days like
is he gonna come at me is he gonna
attack me is he safe
is he bad you know so i think that
really hits like a gene or a
like a wiring in in the ladies yeah i
think so and all but i do
there are reality shows i like i mean i
i definitely i'll youtube
old blind date episodes like this is
[ __ ] great
that's great but that's so much that's
so silly and tongue-in-cheek
yeah i'm very self-aware yeah like the
bachelor i watch with her
it's just tear after tear i grew up in a
house with
my dad he used to hit us with a wrench
and
lock us in a room with no water and
you're like what the [ __ ] is going this
is a date
i'm supposed to marry this this lady but
you know
but you've done reality tv and so have i
so we both know
that they're prodding you and that
they're trying to push like i remember
doing america's got talent they
they were trying to get me to trash
comics on before me they'd be like what
do you think of him i was like
no comment i remember they would just
try to get me to say [ __ ] they'd be like
so ha
so how do you feel they would try to
just get me angry and worked up
they sit you in a room on america's got
talent for 12 hours straight
yeah with no snacks or anything kids
getting detained at the border are
getting better treatment and i got
america's got talent yeah i did last
comic standing they hated me because
they want to pin you against each other
and if they want it to be a real
competition they'd be like
what do you think out there you think
you're going to beat johnson or how do
you feel you're going to win this thing
i was like probably not
i don't have it i'm not that interesting
i'm a four-year comic
this guy's great they're like what are
you doing and i'm like hey i don't know
i'm not
i can't beat this guy it's gary goldman
or whatever i know
that's the thing they want to make you
innocent they want to make you into a
villain
or or something you know mackie was so
smart about that when he was on the last
comic too
i remember agt they just try to piss you
off like simon cowell's in a bad mood
like so am i and i'm not going home to a
[ __ ] yacht
so uh right right that's the lyrics
they try to bait you they would try to
just [ __ ] piss you off and i remember
just so many oh so many i remember they
put me in a [ __ ] hotel with
construction so i couldn't sleep so i
came in extra irritable
and they do they ask questions like how
excited are you for the possibility to
win and i remember being like well
if you win you have to do a residency in
vegas right and they say yeah i go
[ __ ] hate vegas and they were like we
can't use anything you're saying i was
like good i just want you to use a
stand-up i don't want to
i don't want a sob story i just want
jokes on tv and
that's that's hilarious and they just
keep lying to you the whole time
like even the host is up there it's some
sea crest or nick cannon
anti-semite whoever it is and they're
like hey folks
the funniest comic is battling it out
it's like no it's not
it's the comic with the war story or the
dead mom
or the gay dog or whatever it is it
ain't the funniest it's the guy with the
big
narrative we can all get behind and have
a sob story
my wife was in nam and her legs got
blown off so i have to do jokes to pay
the rent and uh
hey this joke's got legs unlike her
you're like what the [ __ ]
i was about to stand up
his name is charlie so it's weird anyway
uh no it's uh it's the worst man yeah
agt last comic
who was you weren't on were you on the
year i was on last comic i think you
were right
ah what no you know i think you were the
year before me yeah yeah i'm trying to
remember who was in my group but it was
a weird
it was like louis gomez greer barnes
uh metzger
damn oh man i remember metro that
michael jackson joke that made it on it
was like one of the best jokes i've ever
heard
that was great he's incredible he's an
incredible writer
genius him and kyle dunnigan have teamed
up and it's like some of the best comedy
yeah in a while it's amazing on
instagram kyle dunnigan's got one of my
favorite jokes of all time
you know the one i'm talking about where
uh he's
said my uh some women accuse me of
having too close a relationship with my
mom
but mother says all those women are
jealous little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
man he is so funny he's amazing his
instagram is the best
it's the best like i show it to friends
who aren't in comedy and they're like
this is g who is this guy and i'm like
it's next level it's the funniest [ __ ]
like you're not gonna see anything this
funny on comedy central or
or uh like netflix or whatever this is
just balls out
smart silly topical
humor it's got everything it's
impressions it's musical it's jokes
yeah he's got the his bill mars caitlyn
jenner they're [ __ ] gold
oh so gold i mean the barack obama and
the devil
did you see uh dana carvey's joe biden
yeah that's the first good biden i've
seen
every other [ __ ] every other bite and
i'm like all right
that's a good biden jim carrey's is uh
not great let's be honest i mean we all
love
gary i don't think jim carrey has
watched footage of biden i think he was
like i'm just gonna do what i want to do
he's doing fire marshall bill it's not
even biden
it's like when famous people go to
restaurants and they're like i will have
the uh
chicken and like we don't we don't have
chicken they're like could you make a
chicken and they're just like
i guess yeah that's his biden yeah
yeah it's like jim carrey's just kind of
pushing a button he goes to a restaurant
what are you having sir
all righty then like well that's not an
order
oh dude yeah i gotta pee if i gotta pee
for you oh
you're peeve or a email i'm doing one of
mine
oh great and it's going off a past peeve
of yours people that say you know all
the time
oh yeah i had a guy doing that
to me wouldn't stop every line you know
you know
you know uh and it should i shouldn't it
was like so i was sleeping with my wife
you know and i'm like no
i don't yeah yeah
stop making me valid you should be
you're the one talking
you should be bringing something to the
table but you need me to keep reassuring
you
you wish to reassure me with your fun
idea or good story or joke
i'm not a fan yeah that it's just work
for you you know yeah i know yeah uh-huh
you know
yep i got it let me do you have a box i
can check real quick do you have a
a stylus i can do yeah yeah exactly
i got a peeve too but hey let's uh let's
hit this ad real quick we got a
doozy this week oh what do we got mark
i love these guys we are brought to you
by sheath underwear baby i'm wearing
them right now i swear to god i can
stand up and show you [ __ ] it i'll do it
i'm not wearing pants
wow oh my god did you see that
this might get us thrown off youtube but
we'll get on grinder and only fans
but uh yeah sheath underwear it's the
best it's this genius
military guy who figured hey i was out
in the the
the [ __ ] and my balls are sticking uh my
[ __ ] and all this [ __ ] and i'm
sweating and it separates
the dick from the sack in a in a flap
situation
and these two dick and balls have been
they've been living in a studio their
whole lives they finally got a
two-bedroom now they can go in their own
compartments and
relax for five seconds and it's a game
changer
keeps your ball you're supportive too
they're supportive you know
like the way women get support in their
bras we got that in our nuts now fellas
they support that sack it's not gonna
drag anymore
and i i i wore them too they were a
little too small i gotta get another
pair sent to me sheath if you're
listening i'll take another a
large place and uh you know it's amazing
go to sheath underwear dot com
order with promo code drunk and you get
20 off your first first order this is
they have great everything though it's
not just the underwear everything on the
site is
great the shirts everything uh 100 money
back guarantee
if uh if you're not happy that sheath
underwear.com promo code drunk
yes yes and go to sheath underwear and
let them support
your balls i'm just they look great
they're sexy
uh my gal likes them it's just a game
changer get that support
and uh once you go with supportive
undies you're never gonna go back
so uh give it a shot folks treat
yourself and treat your package
it's great my gerbil loves him he's
really just
great 20 off your first order and uh
definitely give it a shot guys
nice pepe the you know guy i'm so with
you
oh i'm with you man let's do one should
we do one more peeve oh sure
mark t tetsy i hate when i get wasted
with my friends
and they want to talk about important
[ __ ] while we're [ __ ] up
like if your friend says where do you
see yourself in three years i'm like
dude i'm trying to stay hydrated enough
to avoid blacking out
i'm more worried about where i see
myself in 30 minutes and how i'm getting
home huge fan of the of you guys
hilarious pod
macklin that's a good point hey we're
here to booze and
and [ __ ] take it easy with the
miscarriage talk
that is the seri there is a drunk like
that who's very serious
yeah oh yeah for sure and and i get it
you know
we're friends you got something going
down but like you gotta you gotta
couch it like hey man well after a few
more can i take you off to the side
i gotta ask you something like we we
call that a phil hanley you know when
phil hanley's like can we go over here
and talk i'm like
ah just tell me right here what do you
got me these are these glasses these
glasses are great phil got him for me
oh nice they're dainty just like he is
but uh
no man you're right it is like a it is
the serious drunk they turn into like
marlon brando and on the waterfront
yeah i could have been a contender all
right dude i'm sorry what do you want me
to do about it it's a lot
it's a lot and then plus with the booze
the booze infused it makes them more
passionate
and more angry and like they start
emoting more and you're like all right
all right
this is not weird [ __ ] uh fuddruckers
buddy take it easy
we'll get you and i will get fired up
sometimes when we're drunk but i feel
like it's passion
yeah that's different that's different
this is like oh
you know my my mom left my dad and
they're like all right all right
yeah here's what you don't want to be
toasting to and that's when i found out
i was adopted
cheers exactly and then
here's the trade-off if you're gonna
open up with some crazy sad dramatic
thing
we'll listen but we get to try we get to
make fun of it too
oh totally yeah if you if you go i got
molested and say well put down that
daiquiri
yeah yeah yeah exactly
yes he'll have two fingers of whiskey
sorry sorry
no it's i mean if you want to be the
serious guy you got
i have a friend who's got a temper when
he drinks and it's [ __ ] hilarious
i mean it you can't help but [ __ ] with a
guy because
they get so worked up they it's like
it's
childhood [ __ ] we were like yeah the kid
who lets it roll off his back doesn't
get teased
right right it's the same [ __ ] when
you're an adult if you're like hahaha
but if the guy's like what the [ __ ] did
you just say to me you're like i'm gonna
keep making fun of you
yeah yeah yeah that's so true if you
give us a reaction we're gonna keep
going so just
own it and it'll go away like i used to
wet the bed and i would come out of
the bedroom going hey boys guess who
just marked their territory
i would get i would get ahead of it
that's good
it is good to own it yeah it's like
eight mile you know right right exactly
i can't
you can't follow the guy who just shits
on himself oh completely
yeah mom spaghetti uh all right i gotta
i got a couple pet peeves and tell me
where you feel where you land on this
one i'm excited
i hate now this is kind of a elaborate
but i hate the
break even gift i had a guy break two of
my
scotch glasses which is fine it happens
you know everybody's human
but then he got me two scotch glasses
like he's some kind of hero like
happy birthday merry christmas i'm like
no no we're even now
don't act like you're uh al capone
coming in with a turkey
on thanksgiving to the poor family you
broke the glass here you repaid the
glasses i appreciate it
yeah you're a man of your word or
whatever the hell but uh
we're even now absolutely and were they
the same glasses or did he go cheaper
did he go better what was the
deal there i think they're the same but
it's still
new so it and they're shiny and clean so
it's
it's better i guess but they're the same
glasses
yeah you break it you buy it that's what
i always i mean look if it's a friend i
i have friends if they broke it but yeah
whatever but it is
it is the right thing to do if you break
someone's [ __ ]
yeah and he didn't even have to replace
it look i can afford two glasses it's no
big deal
it happens all the time but uh it was
just like the
here you go you're welcome i'm the man
uh you're you're you're lucky i'm your
friend i was like all right all right
you broke even yeah i'm with you i think
when they present it like i got you
something yeah
yeah like he did it in front of the girl
and he was like good guy over here huh
who else would do this and she's like
i don't know it's a cup two things that
bugged me about that one
is that you get you're doing it for an
audience hey everybody look what i got
look what i got like everyone's
applauding you and they're like look
i'm a [ __ ] hero that's one exactly
two
two is just the wanting attention for
doing you should be like hey i'm really
sorry again here you go
that's keep it simple keep it simple
classy
less is more less is more that's that's
the move i think
yeah now here's the one that we've all
we can all get behind and i hope i
haven't done this before but
i hate the prank joke uh
i i had a guy do this and he's a buddy
but he does this all the time
and he'll go like i'm trying to think of
a good one
we'll be at his house he's like what are
you crazy don't sit there that's a good
[ __ ] you can't
you're like oh geez sorry he goes i'm
joking and you're like
oh all right you freaked me out i mean
no one's laughing here
this is that's not really a joke that's
just like you scared me
and got amused by it well the [ __ ]
thing is there are people that treat
their house like a museum
so you are actually on edge and you're
just like all right i guess i can't
touch anything here you know but
right uh yeah the phrase when you are at
a friend's house is mikasa sukasa
you know it's not supposed to be mikasa
as uh my amusement park where i just
[ __ ] with you the entire time
so yeah i hate that that's infuriating
but he'll do it anywhere at a restaurant
and he'll find like oh what are you
crazy you can't touch that and you're
like oh sorry i don't know you know i
grew up with a scary dad would yell yeah
i go i go back to a kid i'm like i'm
sorry
whatever you want you know my dad will
get mad if he touched the walls he's
like don't touch the wall get your hand
off the walls i was like okay sorry dad
but new people they don't know him so
they're like okay and then he's like i'm
joking
chill out like chill out he just yelled
at me
it's the worst it's a hidden prank show
for an audience of one no one finds it
funny but him
exactly and you can't relax and i'll go
so far to say it's almost a weird power
thing like
yeah oh i got you there i'm in control
you have to
bow to me and then you get you hide it
behind the the sheath of i'm joking
you're like well you just mean to be and
then you say you're joking so it's cool
i don't know it's it's not fun it's not
fun for anybody except that guy
it's the worst type of frat boy [ __ ]
it's
it's like another one people like this
dude though like
you know the person that used to like
they'd be drunk like twist your nipple
yeah yeah well you're like hey don't
[ __ ] do that
it's pretty simple no one likes that i
remember a guy who [ __ ] ran a club
did that to me and i was like
if you do that again i will never set
foot in here again
we're we're grown-ups man what are you
i'm not i kind of was like blunt like
hey that's
i will not come back here it hurts
it it hurts and it's also like your
[ __ ] tool you're
yeah the biggest tool yeah who is that
for who like who's like oh
good one buddy yeah my nips are bleeding
and uh that was fun like no one enjoys
that i don't care who you are the
funnest guy van wilder nobody's into it
man wilder ain't doing that [ __ ] no
let's have a scotch
and laugh it's a bitch-ass move it's an
insecure guy who's like
this it's like what you said it's like
it's a power thing yeah
it's it's some napoleon [ __ ] right
and i think
we talk about toxic masculinity and i
hate all these labels and terms but like
growing up when i when i was younger
that was a lot of dudes hanging out
and i never i hated it then me too i
like jokes i like stories i like
laughing
i'll wrestle with you i'll do whatever
will play ball but
who the hell wants to be hurt like a lot
it was a lot of headlocks and noogies
and wet willies and i always hated that
[ __ ]
you know what it is i think i think we
kind of grew up with similar heroes
you know we i think we looked up to like
you know bill murray the guy who would
say
the funny witty thing and he was cool
because he was always the wittiest
as opposed to like these kids were like
porkys i want to be like those guys
right hey right yeah good point and and
bill murray if he did
zing yeah he was zinging the judge or
the army drill sergeant
or the mayor or you know he was he was
the everyman
zinging the the authority it was like a
heckler video
but in a movie it was kind of like it
was we were living vicariously through
him i mean it was
it was the best perfect perfect point
perfect
yeah bill murray it's a perfect example
man he was he was i mean he's still the
coolest
i haven't seen the new sophia coppola
movie but i'd like to
oh i didn't know there was one uh
it's it's him and uh that really
attractive actress who's
quincy uh quincy jones star yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's pretty
yeah oh yeah yeah he's so good like
lost in translation i don't even know
how good of a movie it was but i just
like to watch him exist in the world
he's he's with the asian people he's
drinking a whiskey
he's at a hotel he's in china or
wherever japan it was just fun to watch
if you could get lit up drunk with any
famous person to see top of the list
oh hands down i mean he's number one
maybe number one i mean i would say
larry david but he doesn't drink so it
would just be me being like dude
the puffy shirt yeah oh and he'd be like
ah geez
get this [ __ ] out of here
but uh yeah bill murray's up there for
sure
he's up there well what about you i mean
paul newman would be cool but he's dead
so like there's a lot of people who
dangerfield if you were alive would be
pretty great god
that would be incredible because you
just know it would be a [ __ ]
ugly night it would start like you'd
start just having like a beer at a
chinese restaurant and you end up in
some [ __ ]
gutter you know he's just pissing on the
side of a building you're like this is
kind of
yeah that's one that's one uh for the
books that would get dark really
oh i know this girl veronica she'll take
care of both of us
how did we get here
yeah i don't get no respect
hey let me borrow 100. i'm a little shy
you'll never see that again this broads
into some yellow discipline all right
this chick she'll hit you with a shoe
i'll tell you
i'll tell you she stepped on my nuts and
i bled she's all right you know she's
all right she's a good girl
good girl really seems to care
uh yeah yeah uh yeah so that would be
great but
yeah that would give you major fields up
there yeah i mean
that's the thing is like prior would be
funny as hell but it would get so dark
oh yeah yeah you ever seen that video of
prior doing blow
and on an interview and he's so high
he's not actually doing it on camera but
he's so
coked out and i've never even done coke
but i can just tell he's
like you know he's licking his lips and
doing all this [ __ ] and he's talking
about how brilliant steve martin is
and he's talking about loving young
[ __ ] and the the uh
the interview was like oh yeah it's like
a british guy going okay i think we got
it here and he just won't stop
it's unreal it's on youtube somewhere
look i gotta find that man prior uh i
rewatched
uh some old prior [ __ ] recently just
because it's so
it's important he's like a dude you
gotta re-watch every year because you
keep seeing it differently you keep
being like oh man he's uh so true
he's so funny i mean just if you haven't
even if you watch the first
15 minutes alive in concert just the
riffing the
comfortableness the this is a special i
mean this was in theaters like
the pressure of a comedy special back
then was
enormous now it's like ah we'll shoot
someone put on youtube and
back then i mean it is for us but back
then it was like
this is going on the the movie theaters
and he just ringed winged it and killed
it and it was
you felt like you were there you know
some things don't translate on tv
this is like you're in the room that's
such a good point yeah
high pressure in a theater like yeah
it's a big
you know you did you brought back the
toast thing for this podcast
i want to do a toast but this is a weird
one
because it's not as it's not as abstract
as the one you did a toast to uh
jessica walter man legend r.i.p the
great jessica walter
and george siegel died this week too who
i [ __ ] i loved just shooting me
growing up i loved you yeah
that was a great sitcom great sitcom
underrated so underrated spade is great
and it's
uh wendy malik is brilliant i think i
think so underrated uh
yeah that just had a murderer's role on
it and it was
a joke a minute it was so fun and and
punchy
yeah great show it doesn't get it's due
and another movie california split one
of my faves
robert altman george siegel and elliot
gould badass
it's incredible louie actually turned me
onto it it's great
uh years ago yeah it's a great movie
yeah jessica walter man i mean obviously
arrested development but archer's
i love her on archer man archer i did a
deep dive once when she died because i
was like man this is so sad
and she's done tons of voices she's been
in tons of comedy like she's
she's got a resume on her yeah and she
just lost her husband i think ron
liebman like a
a couple years ago but they were yeah i
mean [ __ ]
legend like insanely funny who could
play
such a good wasp and she was pretty old
and you didn't feel it like she had a
her she was so funny that it had a
youthfulness and
yes you know you didn't think like oh
who's this old you know sometimes they
have the grandma jokes
you know like rapping granny or whatever
and you're like oh she's cute
you know betty white kind of [ __ ] this
was just funny flat out funny for funny
sake it wasn't like
funny because she's old exactly she had
an edge
yes completely it was like an honesty to
that character
uh lucille bluth such a honesty to it
and uh
such a brilliant comedic actress and
also like you're right a woman of that
age
getting such significant roles i don't
think that was
very i think was very normal back then i
agree and
one great thing about comedy comedy we
just want funny we don't care if you're
black white
lady old you know young whatever we just
want funny and she was funny
you know where hollywood thinks they're
so progressive they won't book old
people unless they're playing
yes cool whereas comey's like oh she's
funny put her on
that's a great point yeah funny funny is
over everything that and there's an
honesty to that
so yes yeah pretty cool exactly good
good luck as a 45 year old or plus in
hollywood you know
it's kathy bates meryl streep and then
they're like ah we'll get uh
put some makeup on on natalie portman
that is the fun was that you had the bit
about like how just ugging up uh
yeah just ugging up actors to get them
other [ __ ] roles it's like
yeah yeah like brad pitt is just ugly in
this movie charlize theron is just ugly
in this movie and you're like all right
exactly they're ugly people exist
i know i mean if we're going to book uh
autistic people to play out to
our trans people to play trans people
what about the uggos
problem is ugly people don't identify as
ugly
that's the key that's why we can still
make fun of them
because they don't have a guess there's
not like the ugly union
it is interesting because i guess like
forrest gump i know he went like half or
is whatever they say it but
he got that one that's not getting made
today
no and it's beloved it was best picture
i think
i mean i am sam he went hard that was
pretty [ __ ]
you want to say like this is [ __ ]
nuts yeah that was
way too [ __ ] like he went all in and
it wasn't even fun
it wasn't fun [ __ ] it was like sad
yeah it was
sad and then the daughter and the whole
thing
yeah it was like was it i remember
seeing it like on a flight it was a
custody battle or something
yeah it was something i think was dakota
fanning it was one of the fannings i
think
yeah by the way she's held it together
kid actor-wise you know a lot of
i was watching her and going she's gonna
be [ __ ] he's gonna go lindsay lohan on
us or ricky schroeder or one of these
things and she
she hung in there she seems sane
yeah i don't know how these kids do it
you see corey feldman you're like that
poor guy man he does not
like he must have had it rough as a kid
in hollywood
i mean where the hell's corey haim
that's all that's all you need to know
yeah you know what's weird is he he
he's hung around it's funny when you see
a kid you're like well this kid must
have it all
you know yeah i know and then his life
is like because
he's funny as helen gooney is it's a kid
actor he's amazing
i always there's something bad about
that that huge rise like
i think everything ebbs and flows in
life look bill cosby's saying pull your
pants up wearing a sweater but then he's
the worst human being on earth
everything evens out and i think if you
go that high that early you gotta go
low that early and it's good to just you
know do what we do and barely make it
for 40 years and then we'll pop uh when
we're 61 and people go hey we're great
and then we'll die
we'll be on dialysis soon like good news
you just pop
yeah yeah exactly right
you finally uh are doing theaters
you got uh you got any wrecks i got too
many wrecks so i'll
blow do as many do as many as you feel
man well
as a guy on the road i'm on a flight
every 10 seconds and i'm a big movie on
the flight guy because for once in your
life your phone is off you can really
escape
and put the headphones on and just zone
into that movie like we used to do
back when uh you know there wasn't
facebook and all this [ __ ] tick tock
and i re-watched white men can't jump
and i gotta say that is in my top five
movies it's just so
funny it's so well done it captures that
time
i grew up in a black neighborhood so
that like hits home for me with all the
all the like the hip-hop stuff and the
the basketball culture
and man do i love that and some of those
jokes hold up
and they're funnier than any comedy you
see
i gotta i gotta be watching i loved it
as a kid i remember i mean
when woody dunks you're just so happy
and and wesley wesley
is really funny i mean that's the thing
uh yeah it's a great fifth element like
he's funny and
demolition man he's really underrated
demolition man he's great yeah wesley is
really
he really got [ __ ] with that tax [ __ ]
that really sucked
yeah uh but yeah woody and what i mean
just the idea of
it it's a buddy comedy i mean the two
guys completely
who kind of can't stand each other
having to work together it's a cop buddy
comedy essentially right
yeah they just found a new format you
know a new structure
basketball street ball uh i think it's a
ron
singleton johnson john singleton did he
make it
i think he did or ron shelton one of
those guys i think he's dead now
either way but john singleton passed
away i know yeah
it was but it's just so good and ron
shelton
branch okay i was always way off but
he's uh
it's just so you love both of them and
you want them to succeed there's never a
lull there's never a abort there's a
weird
part where the only hiccup in that movie
is rosie perez is learning
she like loves fun facts and one of the
facts she learns is
foods to start with the letter q and
then she goes on jeopardy and that's a
category it's like all right well this
is
a little bit of a leap here but uh we'll
we'll allow it it's hollywood
you know the q and on people are like we
told you do you see what that is
we told you they predicted it yeah no
she's so hot in that movie and she's
still kind of hot i think i mean
your tits are just jumping around and
you're like what this is great
um they never really come at you with
them but they're just hanging out of a
tank top over here it's fun
woody harrelson has had such a cool
career
i love that guy he's just good in
everything he's good in dramas or
comedies or whatever he just rules
was it one true detective but then he's
in uh he's in a
no country for old man then he's a white
man can't jump then he's in um
what's that with that zombieland like
he's everything he's all over people
versus larry flint he's great in that
great in that um yeah no it's it's
insane dude his resume is insane and
he's
kingpin dude kingpin love it
speaking of bill murray before [ __ ] oh
that's a good that's a good ass movie
that is so i saw that on a date and i i
totally lost interest in the girl i was
like
[Laughter]
you know what it is you ever see a
really funny movie on a first date and
she doesn't think it's that funny and
you're like miserable
that's my thing well like not only are
you not admitting that this is funny
it's almost like they admit that you're
not funny because you're like well i
love this
yeah yeah it's so true but also hey lady
the whole theater is laughing so who's
wrong here
oh i mean unreal unreal
great movie great comedy all right i
also got
i just want to i want to mix and match
here since i'm saying white men can't
jump i'm going all the way on the other
end of the spectrum and i'm throwing out
ladybird
such a good script so you're going to
say birth of a nation of like jesus
yeah roots is great
[Laughter]
uh uh ladybird so good you almost
freudian me so good the acting is
amazing
uh metcalfe what's her name laurie
metcalfe
yeah unbelievable the the irish chick i
can't rory
sorella i can't say that yes she's great
and man she's just like a coming-of-age
perfect capture of the time it's
shot in it's just it's great she's a
great actress and she's great in
everything she's in she's in so many
she's in every she was like
brooklyn was a really good movie she was
in and uh she had a run
a little woman she's a little woman i
mean little woman
uh yeah in a lot of stuff just about
once
it's about one really small woman who
just uh
right right uh yeah those are good so
that's that's a good ladybird i know you
love that movie i remember when it first
came out you you told me it's a good
movie it's it's kind of hard
yeah and then i re-watched band of some
band of brothers i forgot how good that
is that was back never mind
series oh it's great i mean if you like
war stuff it's great
i do yeah and it's a spielberg joint
which is fun
uh but yeah i can keep going i wrote
that and we may destroy you
great show didn't get any love i think
it's it's too real
it's a bbc show with that that crazy
looking
black chick what's her name she's in
some other show called bubble gum like
he's in a lot
she's doing uh uh yeah i know salakis
keeps telling me to watch this
oh i mean it's heavy but it's so honest
that
kayla cole yes she's great i think she
wrote a lot of it or directed a lot of
it
and everyone loves it i gotta give it a
go so real
and it kind of goes against the
narrative so i don't think people
wrote about it that much like the times
didn't write about it and like no
reviews because it's not just saying
like
you know this is bad or this is good
it's just like nah [ __ ] happens on every
side everybody's flawed we're all people
some white people are nice some white
people are bad some women are evil some
women or not it just
it just takes it all out of context it's
great you got to see it
i i've heard amazing things people love
that show um maybe i'll watch it this
week
um it's heavy though so watch out
i'll watch it it's tough a lot of shows
i'll watch like as i'm winding down it's
tough when they just [ __ ] you up you
know but
i know i know it's like the friend who
brings up the miscarriage
you know just we just want to chill what
do you what do you reckon i got a few
wrecks too first off this one's a little
weirder but
you and i both complain about dandruff
this thing little
scrubby thing oh it's green you see that
oh good
call little scalp thing you rub it in
it's great it feels nice too in the
shower a little scalp
rubber rubbed the shampoo in i love you
guys got a real brillo pad up there so
that thing you've got to get in there
i get in there buddy it's great and then
here's another weird one these right
here
these are blue light glasses and if you
watch a show before bed they're like 20
bucks on amazon or wherever you get them
you watch a show before bed it's much
easier on your eyes like sometimes you
watch the show before bed you're like
[ __ ] it's really hard to fall asleep
not anymore baby wow yeah because the
blue light keeps you up
so it's kind of nice that they they cut
them out yeah and then last one
so i told you sometimes they'll do short
stories before bed they it's a nice way
to because like you get that
a whole book we'll take i'll do that too
but short stories i'm um
i get the completion but i get some
closure by the end of the night i kind
of like that
so this is this guy i love this guy
murkami he's great
uh great japanese writer but uh he wrote
is this book called men without women
for some reason it just like works right
now for me because it's about like
isolation and about
men who have dealt with loss like you
know either the women in these stories
have like
they've died or met first story's my
favorite one
and it's basically the the idea of it's
like this old actor like just picture
this old
kind of like washed up character actor
but he had a good career
and he's got a show for chauffeur and
she's this [ __ ] up woman
basically and it starts with all these
like kind of cliches you're kind of like
this is what i love about this writer is
like you always think you kind of know
it's like a great bit where you're like
i know where this is going
i get it but he always [ __ ] you by the
end when you're like jesus i had no idea
it's a slow burn always but uh basically
it's about his wife who died and he
and he kind of tells her how he knew she
was cheating on him with this younger
kind of
flash in the pan actor and it really
[ __ ] him up so he befriends the actor
and
and the actor doesn't know he knows but
he uses it to [ __ ] with him and he's
like i'm
using it to like unravel him and it kind
of
ends i mean maybe i shouldn't say how it
ends but it's it's cool it's
it's only like 40 pages or something
it's really good and uh
yeah he's one of the best writers i
think i love him
oh that's that's like edgar allen poey
kind of
it gets weird and dark and uh
but it's just real it's it's like you
can see why this dude would be so
[ __ ] angry and why he would use it to
torment this other guy and you could
tell he's smarter than him
but you still kind of feel for this
other guy like because the wife's death
affected him as well and he did
something really shitty but he's
hurt by it it's interesting there's
complex characters i love it so
i'm a big fan i'm a big fan so i love it
and uh
you know that's so cool i mean i love
that kind of stuff
i'm so fascinated with these short story
writers because how did
did like a joke i get okay that
something weird happened or you thought
of something in the shower
so you write a joke about it did that
happen to him or did he just create that
whole thing in his mind and said i gotta
get it out
that's so cool to me i don't know i i
would think
and like this is a complete guess
because i have no idea either but
maybe they they i bet they read stories
news stories maybe i bet i bet they just
maybe they know someone kind of like
that you know how they like we'll take
jokes sometimes we're like well this is
kind of true this is like there's truth
to this
even if it's not 100 true there's truth
in here
yes i bet that's what they do
interesting
yeah yeah that might but then they
probably just create they create a world
based off that i'm sure a lot of it's
[ __ ] well i read a fun fact when it
said
like 94 of our thinking is a
replaying memories and uh
creating scenarios you know when you're
fighting with somebody and you're like
oh man you kind of argue with them in
your head and [ __ ] or or
or like you're going on a date so you
kind of like plan the date out in your
head all right it's gonna go like this
then i'm gonna go in for the kiss and
then we're gonna get a drink
and it never works out and all that but
that's most of your thinking and maybe
these guys or these gals who write
who write books are just the best at
that so they're recreating or creating
stuff in their head and they're like
this is pretty good like i'm just making
up [ __ ] in my head i should i should
write this
right like this what could have happened
right right
they're just better at it yeah i mean
that's imagination right i mean that's
just you know
that's what it is to be imaginative so i
guess so yeah but it's
it's uh i read i love reading murder
mystery so it's good to just take a
break with some [ __ ] that's a little
more
grounded yeah but that's still heavy
[ __ ] i mean the cheating with the name
befriending the guy i mean that's
that's a doozy yeah no it's heavy
wow man how do you how do you get the
wrecks with like how do you find these
stories
uh i think my brother turned me on to
murkami originally he
he loves him uh wow and and he
yeah i mean here's another one that's
really would probably be good for right
now because i think it's called i think
it's called after the quake let me
double check the title
but a long time it was great but it's
like you know it's after this awful
earthquake
and it's like you know you go to the
even you know
these clubs and it feels like we got hit
by something so
yeah totally yeah it's called after it's
called uh after the quake
it's another really good one i think now
let me ask you this because you
you read a lot have you ever picked up a
book less than i used to
have you ever gotten 100 pages in going
i [ __ ] hate this
i want to stop but i feel guilty about
stopping but
i totally keep going like what do you do
there do you stop or do you keep going
i stop okay i don't want to just waste
like i don't want to waste like two
weeks
right all right i always wondered that
because my mom is such a nut she's like
i just finished it you know i'm like
it's a for the paid book and she's like
yeah you know i finished it i started it
yeah sometimes i don't like it but i
like it just enough to be like i want to
know what happens but
i guess you could also just look that up
online these days i don't know i yeah i
don't
i don't i don't know um
i really weigh less than i used to i
just get anxious before bed a lot so i
have to really force myself
because it's so easy to throw on like a
30 rock or something yeah
yeah yeah i i've sadly i now put a
podcast here i put one earbud in and
like lay down with a pod it kind of
lulls me to sleep
that makes it so sad because well that
makes sense dude
books on tape the same [ __ ] that totally
makes sense to me
i know but like when i was 15 i just
went to bed i didn't think about it you
know
yeah it's hard to go to bed i'm trying
to take melatonin because melatonin
gives me these
[ __ ] up graphic nightmares really
you ever take it i take it all the time
and you never get nightmares on it
i've been taking it for years so maybe
not and then i don't i never really
remember my dreams
i also sometimes think i can't tell if
it's the combination of alcohol and
sometimes i just take melatonin i get
really bad nightmares but if i drink and
i take it i'm like ooh this is
this ain't pretty yeah yeah i can see
that i get
wacky nightmares when i nap when i'm out
for eight hours or seven hours i'm just
out but when i nap on a plane i wake up
like oh geez
all right i thought i was being attacked
or i was in like a war or something
but the worst one is when you're on a
plane and you conk out and you dream the
plane's crashing and then you just wake
up
and you're like all right you know it's
a great feeling when you have a
nightmare and you wake up and you're
relieved that this is your world like oh
i thought that i thought i was there
this is my actual life this is so thank
god for this
yeah it sucks when you have a nightmare
when you wake up and you're like let me
go back to sleep
that's a bit that's funny i liked it
better when i was getting stabbed by
my nurse practitioner
should we do another pv mail sure yeah i
was looking for a few i couldn't find a
peeve in there
hey pet peeve i just like the peeves
they're easier to riff on here
pet peeve of mine is when someone says
something and you disagree with it and
they immediately change their opinion to
avoid conflict
oh they could say i love the snow and
you say i hate it and they immediately
agree
hey [ __ ] stand your ground you
boring piece of [ __ ]
i could convince you the sky is orange
just because you don't want to have the
slightest
bit of a friendly argument love the pod
guys that's from bob dower
i've been guilty of that and uh
yeah me too because you just want to
avoid i mean i don't agree
i mean you kind of just like oh you
think that and i'll bail
right right yeah and i tend to do it
with like comics i respect bigger comics
some famous guy
he's like oh man i saw this i'm like i
loved it and he's like i hate it i'm
like yeah i hated it too
because i just want him to like me but
he would actually like me more if we
could have an interesting debate about
it
yeah that's true i kind i'll do it to
just devote like if it's politics i'm
kind of just like i don't want to argue
[ __ ] politics for 40 minutes of the
cellar when i haven't seen someone in
in years you know yeah
[Music]
so yeah if it's something that's gonna
maybe put a sour taste in the room
i'll try to i'll try to nip that in the
bud but uh if it's yeah if it's
something
really casual then yeah if it's a movie
or something of course i mean everyone
for some reason politics really can ruin
because you know you never hear anymore
with politics or anything really is
people going
that's a good point i never thought of
it that way i hear you
it's it's always just i need to win i
need to
beat you there's no are you out of your
mind yeah there's no discussion there's
no absorbing what they're saying you're
just throwing facts at each other and
you're like
but we're not getting into a lot a lot
of people who want to have these
arguments
more people are into conspiracy theories
than ever
so you're arguing with people who
sometimes believe just batshit
crazy things and you're just like all
right like what do you what am i going
to do like
talk them out of it they're not you just
kind of have to be like okay
exactly i was talking to someone who
said some really racist [ __ ] to me the
other day and i was like you don't
believe that though and he was just like
he was like no that's
that's true and i was just like all
right i was just like
we argued for like 10 minutes i'm like
what am i going to waste my whole day on
this idiot
exactly i just i absorb it and i move on
i had a guy once time a flat earther
he's like what about flat earth it's
kind of possible it could be a flat
earth there's a horizon
i was like what are you crazy he's like
can you believe the earth is flat i'm
like i can't believe you're allowed to
have a child like we're [ __ ] you could
have a kid
you really think the earth is flat like
come on
billboard said his best he said the
internet is everybody can have a voice
and eventually somebody's gonna say the
earth is flat and it's so true because
if you give anybody a voice they'll just
say crazy [ __ ]
it's it's also it's so true and it's
also like some people have created these
presences
online because they see what gets the
most engagement and what gets the most
engagement is saying something
provocative but also stupid
so true and people want attention more
than they want to even be right so
sometimes people almost do a character
on there
to just build themselves what i'm being
sarcastic well now you have a following
of a bunch of dumb so beware what you're
building here
as well i know and then when if you call
them out on that they get mad at you and
they're like no
no this is who i am you're saying i'm
disingenuous like yes yes and it's okay
just be that character and own it but
like don't get mad at me for calling you
out
i've met you you're like more normal
in real life you're a normal person but
then you go on there and
you're nuts and then they corner you one
you're like all right i love the snow
you know whatever yeah no it's uh
it's it's i i relate to this i'm i'm
like i definitely do what he says even
though it's annoying i get annoyed when
people do it but i do it for sure
this is i got a pet peeve from a british
guy so some of
the is a little a little kooky which is
fun
lee stole says i got a pet peeve
my pet peeve has to be one going into a
store
of any description and the server clerk
i'm english whatever you call them
cashier i don't know
can't seem to finish the conversation
with their colleague before serving you
i'm right here
shut the [ __ ] up and do your job you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i get that you know you're when the
cashier is having a chit chat with the
other cashier or the manager
and look they can have their business
talk but when they're like oh
man did you see that next game and
you're like i'm right here waiting
you can do this conversation anytime
right if they're showing you an
instagram video they're showing their
co-worker an instagram video like come
on man yeah that happened to me the
other day and i was kind of like all
right just be patient
yeah you just got to sit through it
uh no i get that yeah especially in new
york where you're like
it's weird new york's energy has kind of
slowed down a little bit because of the
pandemic you know so
new york feels a little more southern it
used to be so like bam bam bam because
the lines are always so long now the
lines
aren't as long so true great point
and yeah you can kind of just take your
time a little more there's no one on the
sidewalk
and there's a less hustle and bustle
you're right and
i'll tell you we're gonna have to get
back into it and that could be an ugly
transition
well i miss that pace i like i like the
i do too the hustle and bustle pace of
new york i like that you're like all
right let's [ __ ] move it i i like
this i like this energy and
and yeah we'll get back to it it's i was
out last two nights in the west village
and i was like oh it feels [ __ ] back
dude
all right feels pretty good yeah
i mean just getting a cab now you're
like where are all the cabs
but dude there's less demand so there's
less pet peeve
[ __ ] standing on the corner for
20 minutes for a [ __ ] yellow cab
because i know you used to be fighting
off cattle you did it right you're right
now
now i'm like where the [ __ ] is the cab
uber's really [ __ ] the cabs man
because now ubers are way more expensive
they really they are ubers they
they came in low they got the customers
they [ __ ] the cabs
the cab drivers got [ __ ] on their
medallions their medallions are
worthless now so that was a
retirement and now the cabs are [ __ ]
and now we're [ __ ] because we're stuck
with uber but there will be a new
car service but i just missed the yellow
cab i like the ritual of just like cab
you hop in and you move yeah i know all
about the uber [ __ ] because i've
i know because i've heard it from 13 cab
drivers [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
they ruin everything i come here to
support my family and i'm like all right
i'm just trying to get to 33rd street
buddy like i've heard every rant from uh
every gabby when uber came out
but it is pretty [ __ ] up like you know
that they weren't protected at
all like i do it is kind of [ __ ] up
totally um
but you know there is the argument and
look i'm just playing devil's anal here
but like
you know it's like automated uh
automated trucking is coming and all
these truck drivers like what the [ __ ]
are we supposed to do and it's like i
know but we could say the same thing for
horse and buggy guys when the car was
invented and
so on and so on yeah the horse and buggy
guy then you're like [ __ ] a cab that was
probably
that was pretty [ __ ] next level i'm
sure oh yeah i mean we do it
these youtubers are coming in these guys
don't even know how to write a joke they
got 16 million followers and they
they bomb on stage what the [ __ ] you
know yeah that's a good point it's also
like i bet and then
and now the horse and carriage are super
expensive you're like you're like 400
to get to 34th street like hey that's
the [ __ ] shakes kid you know
yeah yeah you're like no wonder this
this horse says scurvy
and you're a registered sex offender i
mean like
those horse guys are the [ __ ] most
degenerate guys they got the flask they
got the top hat
they're wearing sweatpants
it's funny that's like supposed to be
romantic and then you're just like this
is romantic oh [ __ ]
there's a rat in the seat next to me
what the hell i know there's blankets
from the 40s
it's got small pox on it you know like
what are we doing here
[Music]
some guy [ __ ] in the backseat of that
buggy let's be honest
buggy's a [ __ ] funny word dude he's
funny that
that's a david tell jokes like i [ __ ]
an amish woman we did it horse and buggy
style
yes yes sir jebediah that's an old one
he's the best oh yeah he said to me the
other day goes i was on the road man
even the hecklers are getting rusty
uh so good he's the funniest guy
yeah what uh should we anything else we
forgot oh should we do a bit
oh geez yeah i forgot i forgot good
call uh let me see
i got a couple cooking uh
tell me just just tell me this is dumb
and i'll get rid of it
um
uh somebody i did a fat joke on stage
and somebody come up came with me
afterwards like hey i gotta tell you
like fat is
those days are over like fat is a slur
now
and i'm like okay i get that but you
have to admit that it's the only slur
that fluctuates
you can lose and gain weight you can't
do that with
race you know it's not like hey around
the holidays i get real black
something like that you know because you
you can go in and out of fat
interesting but you can't go in and out
of mexican it's just you're mexican or
you're not mexican
are you gay you're not gay yeah you lose
weight people congratulate you you lose
race people are like is she okay right
what's going on with them
yeah yeah
it's tough because you can lose the
weight and we congratulate you no one's
like hey i lost 40 uh
40 mexicans we gotta throw you a party
or whatever it is
it's interesting yeah wait
i think it's it's like this isn't the
funny angle yet but it's like part of
the
weight loss culture is that we
congratulate people so it's like
you can you're by congratulating someone
you're being like you got healthy
i know i know that's part of the you
know
it it throws in the face of the whole
like big is beautiful but i'm like well
your wedding's coming up and you keep
trying to lose weight
so you don't even believe you're
[ __ ]
yeah maybe this is the only time weight
and uh race fluctuates
oprah
hey that's great but then i don't want
some black guy i'd be like oh she's not
black enough i'm like i don't know yeah
i know i'm just [ __ ] fine
that's funny michael jackson i mean
that's got a hack and he's dead
but that's always a big thing like he
used to be black and now he's white
i know it's tough it just played out
it's and it's it's like an old play that
one
that's tough yeah but i think there's
something there i think the idea of race
fluctuating
yeah that'd be kind of nice holidays
yeah yeah like oh i'm dating uh like a
black guy
i'm dating a white chick now so i'm
trying to trying to lose some of my
black and
meet her family before i meet her family
or something like that i don't think
that's going to work out of your mouth
though
yeah yeah maybe i'll change it it's
going to work out a black comic
no joke would work if your race
fluctuated
oh that'd be great i could i'd be a
killer comic if i could fluctuate race
you're going up for your uptown spot
you're like let me get a little shade
here
going back down to the village let me
get a little whiter oh how about i got a
test coming up i'll get more asian i'm
working on my asian just to pass the
test you know something
fluctuating race would be amazing
because you every race has some kind of
purpose then you're going into then
you're going into stereotype territory
and the bit is better you don't want it
to be a stereotype joke
true but i can i keep it positive but
yeah you're right you're right
uh and race fluctuate the premise is
something i don't know what the
what the turn is yeah i think i get
blacker on the holidays we'll we'll hit
but it does need more are you black
around the holidays
around the house what do you what are
you saying when you when you say like
then you're like
you're a little louder at the table is
that the joke no just the joke is like
most people gain a ton of weight around
christmas and thanksgiving
and i'm saying if if race could
fluctuate
it's just a funny sentence to be like oh
around the holidays i get blacker
oh so yeah just like being just
silliness yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but yeah i'm not saying louder
on the table that's that's where your
brain went
well yeah i don't know i don't i'm
thinking of like well you said the other
stereotype of the test i'm like maybe
it's like a stereotype
right right now now just saying like
it'd be funny if
you could fluctuate race um
but yeah yeah it's tough
for that as a slur it's the only slur
you can lose
too you know like if somebody calls you
gay you can't be like all right well
next time you see me i'm gonna be
straight as an arrow
that might be a rachel dolezal joke in
here if you do it right
yeah she lost it and
it wasn't good yeah
yeah that i watched the documentary
about her it's [ __ ] fascinating
she's weird it's an interesting
interesting uh thing because oppression
is bad and so many people
want to be perceived as people who are
oppressed i guess for the street cred
well yeah i mean think about i think
that's how it works and like rap
50 cent got so much respect for being
shot nine times but who the [ __ ] wants
to be shot nine times like exactly
in comedy it's like mentally ill it's
like this guy's [ __ ] up in the head
and that gives you street you're like
because of prior whenever some you know
what i mean yeah drug addict
alcoholic yeah poor i grew up in a
brothels you're like whoa
this guy's got an origin story but i
will say
and nobody wants to admit it jews don't
get the oppression points
it's similar to asia and i think jews
and asians have
been oppressed no uh jews and asians
were both oppressed
but they're doing really well
they're doing pretty well financially
not everyone
but uh you know a lot of them are doing
fairly well
but shouldn't that be more of a of a
high five like not only were you
oppressed
but you turned it a complete 180 and now
are doing
way better than most for the same reason
people like the first superhero movie
but they don't like the second and the
third
you know they like to see the struggle
but they don't like to see
when you're just that person as much ah
it's so
true yeah what is that
it's it's more relatable i mean that's
why we talked about these reality shows
every
that's why they try to sell you is that
because people like that but we just
care about the jokes so that's
what separates us yeah yeah but i think
a lot of people
they're watching the voice or something
at home they want they want the person
who's like my daddy was shot in the face
and
i got pushed off a cliff and i survived
and singing is
i sang and the authorities heard me and
that's when i knew my voice was powerful
and
right yeah all right what do you got
so there's an idea i've been noodling
with this but it's about
how you can't tell you're in a bad
relationship while you're in it
it's like the only thing do you know
what i mean oh for sure yeah
like if you're in a bad thing it's
[ __ ] up but your friends can tell you
can't tell
it's kind of like it's the only thing
that's like that where your phone breaks
you know it's broken yeah your phone is
broken you're not going to be like man
this isn't working your friends are just
like
yeah this looks horrible and and you're
just like you should see it when you're
not around it's actually um
it's actually a pretty good phone and
there's like it looks pretty shitty
like all these angles go off that like
how um
that's interesting then like six months
later you're thinking like uh
it did shut down all the time with no
explanation it just would shut down on
me
yeah it's true it's almost kind of like
childhood
you're just like oh this is what this is
what life is you don't you don't know
and then you go to therapy and they're
like
oh you were you were [ __ ] you know you
were beaten and you were ridiculed and
uh
your mom's a drunk or whatever it is
you're like oh yeah but you don't know
then because you're just in it this is
what this is what life is
right yeah and then you have that your
friend's parents are like you should
sleep over
or we should talk your mom's weird and
you're like what
it's true you don't really see it when
you're in it
you get used to it
trying to think of an analogy there
you get your face i see it
it's an outsider perspective you're as
an outsider you're like oh it's so
obvious but when you're in it it is
tough
yeah there's something about how you're
just used to it yeah
when you've had a cracked screen on your
phone for long enough you forgot what a
regular phone looks like
right right it's like when uh it's like
a fish in a fish tank he just thinks
that's
what living is he's like yeah he's a
tank you get fed and then there's some
fish in the ocean like dude this is
it yeah you're [ __ ] you don't even
realize it kind of like you've been on
coach your whole life and then one time
you get bumped up and you're like
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah i've been living
i've been living like an animal
right right yeah yeah it's so true
you're finally comfortable you're not in
that middle seat
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know the
angle yet but
i'll crack this everybody else can see
it which is sad because you're the one
in the relationship
yeah it's like you have relationship
goggles you know it's like ah
i like that
i like yeah i don't care i don't quite
know yet yeah
huh and then when you get out of it
you're like damn that was bad
yeah i was trying to do the phone thing
like it does shut down on me it did shut
down with no explanation
it was uh kind of
maybe there's something about it it's
all my emails
looked at all my emails yeah yeah i
don't know i'll correct this i'll
practice this week
that is that's a that's so true because
you see i've seen friends in
relationships i'm like what are they
doing
but it just becomes like it's almost
like an addict
where you're like dude you're on heroin
you're nodding off at
the library and you don't even realize
it
it needs to be a relationship
intervention or something
like you need a guy to come in and get
crazy because then you just get mad
yeah your friends you can't do that
because then you're just like do it
[ __ ] you you can't even do it right
after a breakup because you will but
then they're mad when they get back
together
there's no winning that's a good point
until they get a new phone
that's the only time you can say it yes
that's good that's good you get a new
phone and they're like i gotta tell you
that old phone was tough
you never answered your text i couldn't
get a hold of you it was
bad reception no connection no
connection
that's good yeah [ __ ] like a samsung
galaxy what was i thinking yeah
yeah exactly the flip phone really
i don't want to say anything yeah it's
good
i like it i like it man it's been a hot
day it's been a good one
good yeah we had another good round man
we'll wrap it up and
folks at home i i read the emails i read
the tweet they're drinking with us
they put us on it's like a warm bath
they sit back
and just they feel like they're hanging
out with us it's nice i love it man i
like follow us and we might be drunk on
instagram obviously follow mark and
myself
see us on the road uh coming up we'll be
in bridgeport connecticut
cleveland uh ac dc all over
nice good good mark where are you gonna
be
i'm at uh the paramount in austin we
added a show
oh [ __ ] that's a that's a beautiful
venue is it
i don't know that's beautiful yeah yeah
i've walked by it eight thousand times
never went
miami improv i just want to go down to
miami and then live it up
uh wise guys one of my favorites
underrated sleeper
great club tacoma mcgoobies
uh hartford spokane
virginia beach uh portland oregon helium
so yeah a ton of fun a
ton of fun stuff coming up syracuse
that's going to be a fight
but uh yeah tampa raleigh
i got oh nice love raleigh okc
yeah i'm excited
it's going to be a good time and and go
to uh
yeah go to email us at uh we might be
drunk at gmail.com with all your [ __ ]
i'm loving this man this is a good pod
i'm having fun with it
great pot we just got a shout out by
some lady
oh [ __ ] she's like a comedy fan in
brooklyn i think and she gave us a shout
out on youtube she did like the top
10 things to look for in 2020 and we
were we were one of them
wow that's [ __ ] nice yeah nice i love
getting a lady shout out
that's nice leon phelps and tim meadows
used to be the ladies man oh
it's a lady i love that
never saw that movie it's pretty good
it's better than you
will ferrell is [ __ ] funny in it he's
he's the best it's got moments
all right all right i'll check it out
and uh yeah
right in patreon's cooking we're reading
emails reading jokes
wrecks tweets uh drink ideas you name it
so
keep throwing [ __ ] out of cause we've
drank everything on the planet so i need
some new
cocktails for sure and yeah keep
throwing drinks at us i'm loving it keep
throwing your wrecks your peeps your
jokes everything and hit us up on the
patreon patreon.com
slash uh we might be drunk pod
at gmail there you go yeah yeah all
right so we'll see you guys there
yes thank you keep drinking
keep drinking